so just tell me really quickly about
sugar poco why did you decide to start
candy company business has always been a
passion of mine I've always enjoyed
learning about it I've had incredible
collaborations over my career where I've
worked with such great companies and
brands that have taught me a lot but in
the end I was a very small part of that
and I felt like I wanted to be the big
girl and I wanted to be the one making
the decisions and having the pressure
although it's you know tough in the end
to make those decisions I really felt
like I was ready for them and candy came
about because it's been a passion mine
ever since I was a young girl I have
always had a sweet tooth and then the
name sugar Povey I heard it in a meeting
about three years ago and then we just
put the two together and informed this
company so who is your intended customer
as the same two kids or is it aimed at
tennis fans I think my turn the customer
is everyone that enjoys candy and sweets
and likes to have fun with it I'm my
career use it as a treat and kind of
like giving back to myself after a hard
day or I feel like I need a little treat
when I come back home from practice
obviously living a healthy lifestyle is
a huge part of my career in my life but
at the end I know I always you know
always want that little treat and to
feel like I accomplished something and I
gave myself something in return
but it certainly helped me and I've seen
um you know I see how people react to
that little something that they look
forward to when they come home or
something that they think is fun or or
energetic and this is what this company
is all about I when I start a business I
didn't want to be a suit-and-tie type of
um you know owner I wanted to really
enjoy this and have fun with it and I
think that's all the fans that I've
enjoyed the candy are have that type of
personality what's some advice you would
give to your younger self
sometimes when you're especially at a
younger age you're making decisions and
you rush into making those decisions
there are times when I look back or I
feel like it could have taken my time
especially when you feel like you have
the advantage and you don't know what's
around the corner of course you want to
take your opportunities when you have
them but it's always nice to have
options on the table before you you make
that final decision and and really take
your time don't rush into anything that
you might later regret so interesting
what's the toughest decision that you've
had to make
well there's so many different sides to
my career in terms of my tennis there's
obviously the team that you surround
yourself with from the coach to the
physio and you know it becomes your
family in a way and that's such an
important aspect of my sport that that's
always challenging in a way because
everyone has to work together so well
and get along and you know travel and
eat and work together so it's a bit of a
playhouse in a way that you're trying to
create around yourself to make you
perform better is it possible to have
too much success at too young of an age
I think you know success can be divided
in many different terms I think people
see it in a very different way I think I
gained success from an early age because
I accomplished something on the court
but then everything else that I gained
from that I don't think I could have
prepared myself for because when you you
know look towards winning Wimbledon or
dream of it you never know what comes
with that type of victory but you learn
from everything and even if you make
mistakes along the way I think you have
to learn from those mistakes at least to
take the positive out of it is there an
invention like a made-up invention that
you wish was real I don't know I I mean
I'm very much into technology and I
think where are we gonna be in 20 years
and you know how our cars or cars gonna
fly or transportations are going to be
easier there's so many things right now
that I wish would improve but I'd love
to have Wi-Fi on the planes that are
like a little bit more accessible that's
a to humble little wish what are you
most proud of there are a lot of things
I'm proud of in my career and in my life
I guess oh I don't know I don't like to
talk good things about myself but um
I've managed to keep myself grounded for
for most of the time and I am you know I
know I've accomplished a lot on the
court but you know a tennis career such
a small part of life and in a big
picture I guess and you know I I still
surround myself with the same people
that I've had since I was a young girl
and my family and I take care of them
and yeah I think that's that's important
when you're kind of travel around the
world and have a big job what would it
take for you to walk away from it all I
don't think I'd ever want to walk away
from it all in terms of my tennis career
I think it's when you know your body
can't it doesn't allow you to play at a
high level anymore especially when
you've done for so many years I still
believe I have many more years ahead of
me and I would don't see stopping
anywhere near in the future and
everything else I have the passion for
and I do because I I really enjoy the
creative process of things and whether
it's business whether it's design I like
to see something come to life and away
from for maybe just an idea or Nothing
or you know a simple sketch or just a
meeting or an occurrence or travel that
you had and make it into reality